I'd like to talk about salmon cat food
for people tunas under study that you
hope never has to go on and that stupid
fish that doesn't know how rivers work
salmon famously have to fight their way
upstream to spawn but thanks to
hydroelectric dams that's become
increasingly difficult but don't worry
because as we found out recently America
is on it I'm Ben Tracy in Washington
state will introduce you to a piece of
technology known as the salmon you know
you know sometimes sometimes people say
the news has lost its touch but every
now and then they nail it
because a cannon that fires fish through
a tube and over a dam is absolutely
incredible and if you're wondering what
it looks like when they come out the
other side the company that makes it
incidentally called woosh innovations
has produced a spectacular slow-motion
video set to classical music
[Music]
in your darkest moments of despair when
you see a world torn apart by war I want
you to remember that video and think we
can do great things we can do it wait
let me tell you how much I love the
salmon cannon I love it so much we made
our own cannon this week let's see where
this salmon ends up of course situation
the Mideast only getting more
complicated the US has been bombing for
you know it works we know it works
let's try firing two fish somewhere else
Thank You spatulas or it declares
[Applause]
very nice let's try something a little
more difficult you took my daughter from
me what did you expect I'm not trying to
deny it but I don't remember well that's
convenient it costs me your love
clearly this is the greatest object that
has ever been invented so I am emptying
this pocket and let's see how big we can
go on this thing
welcome back I'm Michelle Beadle
incredible footage coming out of Houston
Rockets practice injured making a block
Howard Roku fingers and is accepted to
MIT members the Obama administration is
temporarily there's new report about
Iran's nuclear program
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm glad they didn't s to come down it
gets better
[Applause]
[Music]
15 blade Hey
I quit
[Music]
[Applause]
you